And Islam
has the solution for this happiness.
In surah al assur chapter number 103
verse number 1 to3
Allah says in surah assur
that by the token of time Allah is
taking a promise an oath of time man is
verily in a state of loss. Man is in
except those who have four criteria.
Those who have faith,
those who have righteous deed,
those who invite people is the truth.
Those who invite people to patience and
perseverance.
This surah al Assur is called as rah
nijad the path to salvation
salvation ja is the only true ultimate
happiness
and that's the ultimate true happiness
and the path to ja is also happiness
it doesn't defer
this happiness the continuous feeling of
happiness the psychologist say
irrespective
whether you're enjoying or
Whether you're at peace or distress,
whether in prosperity or poverty,
whether you're healthy or whether you're
sick, this continuous state of happiness
irrespective of your condition is called
true happiness.
So Allah says in the Quran, man is in
kasara loss except those who have immal
that there's no god but Allah and no one
else is worthy of worship. Iman in all
the messengers of Allah subhanaa tala
and Mhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is the last and final messenger.
Imman
in the books of Allah.
Im in the akar.
Im in the angels and iman in kadar in
destiny. These are the six pillars of
im. So those who have belief number one.
Number two
the righteous deed. You should have
righteous deed
and the best righteous deed is salah
then you have
then you have soul fasting then you have
and so on and so forth.
The third category Allah says is
inviting people to truth
that is doing dawa and doing isra. When
you meet a Muslim correct him it's
called islah. When you meet a non-Muslim
do dava invite him to the way of Allah
subhana wa tala. It's compulsory.
Without that you can't go to Jenna. You
may be a very good Muslim. You may be
five times a day. You may have the mark
on your forehead. You may be fasting in
the month of Ramadan. You may be giving
zakat. May have gone for Hajj. But if
you don't do dawa,
if you don't convey the message of Islam
to the non-Muslims according to surah
assur you shall not enter Jenna.
Only dawa is also not sufficient. All
four like very important. Im righteous
deed dava andawas. And the fourth
categories
inviting people to patience and
perseverance. If anyone is missing under
normal circumstances, you shall not go
to Jenna. If Allah wants to forgive you,
if you don't do da and put you in Jenna,
that's Allah's prerogative.
But generally,
one of the criteria besides iman and
righteous deed is
doing dawa and inviting people to
patience and perseverance.
This surah according to Imam Shafi
may Allah have mercy on him he said if
this surah alone was revealed for
humankind it would have been sufficient
for haya only this one surah
and we read in empty number of places
those who have belief and those who
righteous did they go to Jenna in this
verse Allah specifies
the other verses right two important
aspects OF RIGHTEOUS DEED
THERE ARE BASICALLY two criter and but
two important categories of of righteous
deed is dawa
and inviting people to patience and
perseverance.
And Allah says in many places including
surah chapter number 18 verse number 107
and 108 that those who have believed
and those who have done righteous deed
they will enter paradise and will stay
there eternally and the desire would not
be to take anything in exchange. So
Allah says in surah chapter number 18
verse number 107 and 108
that those who believe in those who are
M those who are Muslims and those who
right it they'll go to Jenna eternally
forever. This is ultimate happiness
forever and you would not desire to
exchange for it anything once you enter
Jenna.
You won't like to desire to exchange for
it.